work hard work working hard hard work
work harder work hard hard work hard
work how do you get money to do what you
love you don't write
I lost a load of money when I started
doing what I loved what you do is you
position yourself to succeed so for
example if you're doing something else
and you and you want to do this thing
you love you do it after hours you work
9:00 to 6:00 you get home you kiss the
dog and you go to town right I mean you
start building your equity in your brand
and whatever you're trying to accomplish
after hours you everybody has time stop
watching lost that's a good overheard
right that was a good overheard so you
know what I mean I mean if you want this
if you want bling-bling if you want to
buy the Jets if you want to do work
that's how you get it there are two
rules that I always adhere to and that
is to work hard and be brave and I think
the essence of hard work is one that's
pretty straightforward is that you'll
never be the best-looking you'll never
be the tallest most talented most
capable you'll never have the most money
there will always be someone who's
better at whatever you're doing them
with what you then you are but you can
always be the hardest-working person in
the room and I think the hardest-working
person will always win the one thing I'm
the most happy about in terms of my
career is the fact that I got there
but the grace of God first of all but
short of that I got there just by
working hard not partying with the right
people not compromising myself in any
way or cutting any kind of deals just by
working hard just by plugging along so
on wood as I like to call it I'm a 20
year old one night sensation I always
believed that not still talent can can
take you so far but I think you need to
have the work ethic and the drive to to
achieve your potential I mean I'd say
you know my natural talent you know
probably brought me 50 percent of the
way
but then after that it was all it was
all done - the work that I've done and
the volume of work that I've done over
the you know the last 15 years you know
when I really started to take goal
seriously and you know follow what
you're making this a career I think it
was important thing here that prese
Hardware beat tablet era the work hard
it's going to get both and I believe
everybody does tap town you gotta find
your talent then you gotta work really
really hard and I just strive to be the
best and I think those are the biggest
keys to success but the biggest one of
all is working hard you can't accomplish
anything if you're not in early and out
the latest which I read there I think
some people and maybe I used to think
once you got successful you could you're
successful in it okay you know you can
kind of just relax a little bit and but
that's not the case at all you have to
pedal even harder you have to work even
more there are more opportunities that
need more time and dedication and in
order to do them well you have to really
really hunker down and do the hard work
but I've never been afraid of hard work
and I always tell people when I'm asked
and it's pretty often that I'm asked
about dreams and achieving creative
goals that I always believe that the the
bridge between reality and a dream is
work and I always in moments of despair
and doubt and dark days focus on on the
work I show up and I work and I work in
I work in a work the only thing that you
can control that influences success in
life is how hard you work how honest you
are and how well you deal with others
you can control those uh variables but
less variables it you can't control how
lucky you are although the more you work
the luckier you get you have no
influence on the intellectual
capabilities that God did or did not
give you but you can work as hard as
possible you can be scrupulously honest
so that people respect you and you can
get along with others cuz nobody does
anything by themselves did you have to
pay a price though you personally well I
think that everything is an either-or
you there is a price in everything you
can study or you can go out and play you
can defer to others or you can try to
hog the credit you can be honest
and suffer the consequences or you can
lie cheat and steal and short-term maybe
even advanced but long-term you are
better off if you'll work harder you are
better off if you're honest then you are
better off if you give all this credit
and get them to help you with by helping
them what do you tell others who try to
strike that balance between family and
work and the answer of either/or is
invariably yes you can't go all in one
direction you cannot walk away from your
family for your career on the other hand
if you walk away from your career from
your career for your family you're not
gonna have the money to support the
family and parents all the time are
making those kinds of choices between
career and family they do some of both
and you try to blend the two and that
may not be the perfect answer but that's
a practical answer that I've always told
young people when they go off to college
you have to study and you have to get
good grades but you certainly should
have a good time as well because that's
part of your growing up experience and
there's no point in leading life to
suffer all the time you want to enjoy
life as well as the next person so it's
some balance some blend between the two
I don't think there's any magic in being
successful and I'm not talking about
making a million dollars or a billion
dollars I'm just talking about being
successful I'm talking about being
successful what you guys do at work I
don't think there's any magic you got to
work hard you got to respect the people
around you and you just got to go I've
never met a successful person that
doesn't work hard well I think there's
no no substitute for hard work none zero
I was in India I talked to 200 of the
newly hired individuals and this is I
can say this because I'm of Indian
heritage they always asked me when I go
to India so tell us the one or two
shortcuts they get to your point and I
always say there are no shortcuts you've
got to put in the time and so I think
the first takeaway is there absolutely
no shortcuts it takes time and it takes
a lot of hard work you know it's funny
sometimes I talk to my wife about this
but like hard work is like super
in life and like now like I grew up like
in Berkeley and have any money I played
for the football for the Yellowjackets
oh I was just like a kid in the
neighborhood and now like I have a lot
of money and so like with my kids I'm
like okay now that I'm rich how do I
teach you the value of hard work because
that's really the only important lesson
that I've got but like for all of you I
think most of you out of public
university probably know a little of the
value of hard work
keep that lesson that's the input though
that work is what's important it's that
effort where you learn the secrets that
are super valuable and can change
people's lives and change the world
thank you so much for watching I'd love
to know which of the clips meant the
most to you which one you enjoyed the
most finally I wanted to give a quick
shout out to Shahrukh Hasan thank you so
much for ordering my book it means a lot
to me for those of you who have ordered
the book if you want your chance at a
shout out make sure you email in the
receipts to entering for the draw thank
you guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever you're
one where it is and I'll see you soon